donc une annonce qui a effectivement
provoquée pas mal de surprises
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous ça vous a
étonné oui ça m'a étonné bon on avait
quand même senti une réticence de Madame
Brochu durant les la période électorale
dans la philosophie du gouvernement mais
on pensait qu'il avait eu quand même des
discussions que ça s'est un peu placé
quand même on pourrait dire à posteriori
quand on regarde par exemple la faible
présence de Madame Brochut durant les
pannes électriques peut-être dans le
temps des fêtes on peut voir une
certaine distanciation là peut-être de
Madame brochute dans ce contexte et là
insisté lorsqu'elle a accordé un petit
peu plus tôt une entrevue à Patrice je
suis d'abord et avant tout une
architecte ça a été ça la première
partie de mon mandat et je laisse
l'exécution à quelqu'un d'autre est-ce
que cet aspect là vous étonne pourquoi
il ne mène pas son mandat à terme
surtout que la première chose que le
fait quand elle est arrivée ça a été
prendre le plan stratégique développé
par son prédécesseur de le mettre à la
poubelle et de recommencer on peut
s'attendre à ce que le prochain nous le
prochain PDG face un peu la même chose
pour se mettre Hydro-Québec à la main
donc cette explication là pour moi c'est
pas vraiment il y a des beaux défis au
cours des prochaines années à développer
pour Hydro-Québec mais c'est dans la le
déploiement je pense que le plus le plus
grand intérêt le plus grand plaisir pour
un gestionnaire et d'ailleurs si elle ne
souhaite pas se contenter d'être une
exécutante si on veut elle l'avait
pourtant fait pendant longtemps chez Gaz
Métro relevé des défis mettre en place
des stratégies et les mener à terme donc
de ce côté-là peut-être
en fait ça sème la confusion sais pas si
vous voulez tout le monde se demande si
ce sont les vrais raisons de son départ
en effet on peut pas lire dans ses
pensées mais on peut quand même imaginer
que la structure aussi ou en plus du
conseil d'administration qui est normal
pour une structure comme ça madame rochu
avait à répondre plus ou moins d'un
comité de 4 autres ministres incluant le
Premier ministre ça fait quand même
peut-être difficile à gérer ça rend plus
difficile de prendre des décisions aussi
ou des annonces ou des orientations qui
sont pas nécessairement faciles à
prendre pour les citoyens mais qui
doivent être prises pour le pour le
futur pour la transformation au Québec
donc pas suffisamment les coûts mais
c'est possible encore une fois je suis
pas je suis pas libre mais on sait quand
même une PDG qui a roulé énergie Gaz
Métro en fait pas mal comme elle voulait
pendant des décennies alors de se faire
imposer un peu un carcan je pense que ça
fait difficile pour Madame rocher
donc elle dit que c'est le bon moment
pour partir parce que bon elle a insisté
c'est la fin d'un cycle elle dit que les
finances de la société d'État sont dans
l'ordre qu'on a mis sur pied ce plan
stratégique que tout ira bien par la
suite est-ce que c'est vraiment le bon
moment pour partir monsieur sont
immenses le présentement on a vu avec la
tempête avec le rapport de la
vérification générale des enjeux liés à
la résilience sa capacité du réseau à
répondre à
se résister aux tempêtes mais aussi à la
structure pour quoi faire quand il y a
des pannes donc je pense que de ce côté
là il y a des défis importants madame
Brochu a travaillé fort pour réorienter
un peu Hydro-Québec mais le fait que
même les investissements à pas pu être
fait prévu pour mettre à niveau le
réseau on voit que un décalage entre les
la volonté ou les plans et la
réalisation même à l'intérieur du Québec
et donc il faut régler ce problème là
rapidement parce qu'il va falloir
empiler par-dessus ces plans là déjà des
investissements plus importants pour
pour faire la place aux nouvelles
demandes la demande d'un secteur du
bâtiment dans le secteur des transports
dans l'industrie manufacturée donc on
parle moins mais qui va aussi être
devenir important donc beaucoup de défis
quels sont les priorités absolues pour
celui ou celle qui va vraisemblablement
entamer un nouveau mental pour moi il
faut que ça soit la locomotive au Québec
soit la locomotive de la transition
énergétique ce qui était pas le cas il y
avait une réorientation un peu mais on
mettait encore un peu les pieds sur les
freins donc il faut qu'il y ait au
Québec dise nous on va être là puis on
va répondre puis on va vous assurer de
pouvoir quitter les hydrocarbures
fossiles la première chose ensuite la
résilience donc cette capacité là à
rassurer les gens si on dépend de
l'électricité pour tout mais on peut pas
se permettre d'avoir deux semaines sans
électricité alors il faut trouver des
solutions pour rassurer puis pas juste
rassurer là offrir le service et ensuite
augmenter la production on en a parlé un
peu tout à l'heure ça m'avait parlé il
va falloir nos projections nos modèles
qu'il faudra augmenter au cours des
prochaines décennies et il va falloir
commencer ça rapidement pour pas que ça
soit un frein au transformation de notre
société et dernièrement juste il y a
l'enjeu de quoi faire avec toutes les
demandes toutes les industries qui
veulent s'établir au Québec et pas payer
leur électricité
et on n'a pas un vrai plan pour répondre
à ça pour le moment prochain en fait il
y a des candidats semble-t-il qui
seraient déjà présélectionné par le
conseil d'administration quelles doivent
être les caractéristiques de ce candidat
de celui qui prendra la relève besoin de
comprendre techniquement ce que c'est
cette transition là donc au-delà de la
gestion simple jamais simple au Québec
il faut aussi comprendre la
transformation de la société qui va se
faire au cours des prochaines décennies
pour kidro-québec soit en synchronie
donc on a besoin de quelqu'un qui a une
vision une capacité de se projeter
capacité de communiquer parce qu'il y
aura des des désaccords importants il y
aura des tensions avec les consommateurs
beaucoup de défis pour relever
clairement et on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
Monsieur pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI